mentioned to ensure it is properly
equipped and resourced to deal with the
challenges ahead
madame rest and distinguished members of
the security council
to conclude my statement i want to take
the opportunity to address the warring
issue of the safety and security of
nuclear power plants in ukraine
an accident involving nuclear facilities
in ukraine could have severe
consequences for public health and
environment
and all steps must be taken to avoid it
the possibility of an accident caused by
failure to a reactor's power supply
or the inability to provide regular
maintenance is growing by the day
the forces in effective control of
nuclear power plants in ukraine must
ensure their safe and secure operation
i am extremely concerned that four of
the international atomic energy agency
iaeas seven pillars of the safe and
secure operations of facilities are
reported not implemented
at chernobyl and theriposia
communications must be fully restored
and operating staff must be allowed to
properly carry out their duties and to
do so
free of undue pressure
i would like to echo the secretary
general's support for iaea director
general gross's efforts to develop a
framework to ensure the safety and
security of ukraine's facilities and
welcome the constructive meetings he
held in turkey on 10th march
with the foreign ministers of ukraine
and the russian federation i thank you
very much for your attention
i now give the floor to those council
members who wish to make statements i
give the floor to the representative of
the russian federation
foreign
[Music]
a huge number of human lives
oh
to
uh
consisting of at least 30 biological
laboratories
ministry of defense
institute named after mexico and located
in odessa
it was also conducted by research
centers another city of ukraine kiev and
both government
intern noble
including into the u.s army of medical
research
infectious diseases into the walter reed
army institute researchers
in the able medical research of the u.s
navy and into the usr army uh biological
warfare laboratories and fort destiny
uh describing them in the course of
their daily readings
let me just dwell on the more salient
examples of the products
infections using migratory birds and
this includes
ages
[Music]
funded the biological projects in europe
is
squad
is
of the japanese army whose members by
the way found refuge in the united
states and escaped justice
in the very heart of eastern europe and
in immediate proximity of the russian
border
to public schools
released
laboratory
and what a consequence
international
is
there i
will simply dissolve quite probably over
europe
in any event there's a very high risk
that they will be stolen and used for
terrorist purposes or
uh
[Music]
is
which can selectively target specific
ethnic groups
laboratories within
in ukraine uh when it comes to
particularly dangerous and economically
important infection
there is a growing number of different
german measles um
cases diphtheria and tuberculosis
measles uh went up by a factor of more
than 100.
each country with a high risk of a
outbreak of polar myelomatosis
364
symptomatically is very close to faith
in the united states
because of dangerous ways
platform and using their citizens as
guinea pigs
these experiments were the potential the
risk for the entire country is something
that wanted to do for years and we can
see in this yet another confirmation of
an extraordinary cynicism
of um kiev's mentors who tell us all the
time that they're very concerned by the
fate of the community
leaks otherwise this could lead to the
spread of diseases amongst the
population and we don't know whether
kiev implemented that recommendations
under the leadership of specialists over
the united states who had diplomatic
immunity
that the united states and ukraine are
violating article one of biological and
toxic methods
biological programs
close it up and the ministry of health
tells us
these work were conducted within
framework of a military biological ideal
i would like to address my colleagues
from europe
right next
week
and experimental platform for extremely
dangerous biological trials
which as we have seen with code 19 is
impossible
and if there is such a scenario then all
right
provide confusing information about the
involvement
of
the victorian
assistant
sector of state basically confirmed
that they were dangerous
um
studies being con conducted
which should not end up in the hands of
the russian armed forces end of quote
of ukraine are there no um laboratories
under the control of the
um development technologies pathogens
which could be used
to developed by a weapon so this
document exists in the internet and
research between
pathogens
deployed on objects on the territory of
ukraine
[Music]
so
hundreds laboratories in about 30
countries in the middle east africa
southeast asia and also on the perimeter
of the former ussr
category
about creating an effective verification
mechanism to ensure compliance
washington is conducting on the
territory what the consequences for your
people will be
the reaction will be from our western
colleagues who i'm sure are going to be
saying now that all of this information
is fake and russian prep
delusion and i do not think this will be
helpful to the european people
outbreaks in ukraine or neighboring
states with further spread um and
bringing in their wake up dangerous
diseases
very real
radical nationalist groups in ukraine
work with dangerous pathogens conducted
together with the ministry of defense of
the
immediately accuse the armed forces of
the russian federation of this uh say
that they're striking against scientific
and medical institutions and to or or
link these incidents with the russian
diversionary groups
is a very small partial portion of the
information
is something that we will disseminate in
the very near future as an official
document of security council you will be
able to say
we think it allows duty to keep the
security councils
when it comes to the military biological
activity by the united states in ukraine
it creates real risk for international
peace and security and we intend to
revert to the discussion of this topic
in the very near future
we do not exclude the possibility of
invoking the mechanism of articles five
and six of the biological women's
convention
at present however we expect to hear
responses from the america
i thank you madam president
i would like to thank the representative
of the russian federation
and are you the former representative
of albania
thank you madam president
let me thank you gdcarlo and eugene
commissioner for their information
i would like to make the following
points
first we meet at the request of russia
following allegations on a possible
program of development of biological
weapons in ukraine
we listen to their statement very
carefully
madam president
any issue regarding weapons of mass
destruction should never be taken
lightly
as we heard from the usg the united
nations is not aware of any of the
alleged programming consistent with
international treaty obligations
including on chemical or biological
weapons
we heard about health facilities in
ukraine
we have heard repeatedly also a firm
rebuttal at the highest levels for both
the us and ukraine
therefore russia's allegations are in
our opinion
part of the information warfare false
unsubstantiated part of the legal
propaganda and disinformation come from
russia
conspiracy theories not worth our time
the council should be served
should not be served with fantasies or
story-eyed stories but with proof
independently verified and corroborated
this is not the
case however regrettable all this is it
is hardly surprising since everything
absolutely everything we have been
hearing from russia regarding ukraine
has been false fabricated or distorted
these are all in the public space
and do not deserve mentioning but the
real palm door
goes to the russian declaration just two
days ago according to which russia has
not attacked ukraine
well as we saw last week the general
assembly has a different account
in every other situation everyone would
have thought that this is a joke except
for the fact that this joke
is destroying a country
is killing millions and responsible for
the 2.5 million refugees and country
that translates to 7 000 people per hour
reportedly this is also responsible for
the death of several thousand russian
soldiers
this is an issue for russia and its
people
all the more reasons
for the immediate cease-fire and leave
place to negotiations
second madam president
russia has a long and well documented
track record of using chemical weapons
including in attempts as in attempted
assassinations and in poisoning its own
citizens like the jailed opposition
leader alexey navalny or the scriptures
the incap reporting has been brilliantly
able to make it during a direct and
irrefutable link of the attempted deadly
planning with gru high officials
we could therefore be very worried that
in spreading such disinformation a
crescendo of allegations about weapons
of destruction could serve as yet
another pretext russia to prepare the
ground and use chemical or biological
weapons during its in-going invasion of
ukraine while accusing others
after all russia has accused ukraine of
genocide in donbass which is ridiculous
it has also accused cave of seeking to
produce nuclear weapons which is
outrageous
has accused ukraine bombarding its own
citizens which is postures
as we have heard many times including
yesterday russia has continues to
support the regime of bashar al-assad in
syria which has used chemical weapons
against the civil population
should retain what should we attend this
start time is the escalating situation
that is wrecking two countries
threatening a whole continent and
disrupting the entire world
fifteen days into this brutal invasion
and the growing ormond might of russia
with the open complicity of belarus
has stalled before the steel club and
indisputable right of a nation to defend
its land
russia's goals are as abhorrent as the
means it is using to achieve them
we are horrified by the catastrophic
situation in mario paul another besieged
cities where civilians are starved
by the use of cluster ammunition and in
urban areas as we heard during the
briefing
by the redoubling of blind shelling and
bombardments
by more than 26 assaults various
facilities or
including ambulances
as confirmed by the who and confirmed
during this meeting
by outrageous and immoral acts which
constitute war crimes
these are facts
nothing seems to be going as planned in
ukraine
the unprovoked unjustified and
premeditated act of aggression by russia
again with the complicity of belarus
lacks illegal or moral ground the very
ones that in turn empower ukrainians to
fight rightly be ready to die for the
ideals they believe in for the right to
choose who they want to be to be shapers
of their own destiny
in this respect we welcome the
conclusions of the european council
which among others welcomed the will of
ukraine to join the european union
we are
warm-hearted by the ukrainian resistance
incomprehensible made to the invader and
which should be seen as an inspiration
and a reminder that freedom always
prevails over tyranny
let's not forget colleagues
if russia makes its way into ukraine it
will not stop there
it will want more
and
as history meets us
aggression works like a drug
this is why david must and will
thank you mr president
and thank to our briefers for your
remarks this morning
rush to ask the security council for
today's meeting for the sole purpose
of lying and spreading disinformation
and that is exactly what you have heard
from the russian pr this morning
you also heard from this
nakamisu
that the u.n is not aware of any
biological or chemical weapons programs
in ukraine
last month secretary blinken laid out
with tragic accuracy
what russia was about to do
he specifically warned that russia would
manufacture a pretext for attack
and even cautioned
that russia fabricate allegations about
chemical or biological weapons to
justify its own violent attacks against
the ukrainian people today the world is
watching russia do exactly what we
warned it would
russia is attempting to use the security
council to legitimize disinformation and
deceive people to justify president
putin's war of choice against the
ukrainian people
and china too has been spreading
disinformation in support of russia's
outrageous claims
i will say this once
ukraine does not have a biological
weapons program
there are no ukrainian biological
weapons laboratories supported by the
united states
not near russia's border or anywhere
so here are the facts
ukraine owns and operates its own public
health laboratory infrastructure
these facilities make it possible to
detect and diagnose diseases like coke
19
which benefit us all
the united states has assisted ukraine
to do this safely and securely
this is work that has been done proudly
clearly and out in the open
this work has everything to do with
protecting the health of people it has
absolutely nothing
absolutely nothing to do with biological
weapons
in fact it is russia that has long
maintained a biological weapon program
in violation of international law
it is russia that has held
a dominant history of using chemical
weapons
it is russia who is the aggressor here
it was russia's russian operatives who
poisoned alexey navalny and sergey and
yulia skripal with nerve agents
it is russia that continues to support
the assad regime in syria and shield it
from accountability when the un and the
opcw have confirmed that assad has
repeatedly used chemical weapons over
the past several years
we're deeply concerned that russia's
calling for this meeting is a potential
false flag effort in action
exactly the kind we have been warning
about including from secretary blinken
here in the security council last month
has a crack record of falsely accusing
other countries of the very violations
that russia itself is perpetrating
and given that
and consistent with our previous
statements we have serious concerns that
russia may be planning to use chemical
or biological agents against the
ukrainian people
the attempt intent behind these lies
seemed clear
and it is deeply troubling
we believe russia could use chemical or
biological agents for assassination
part of the staged or false flag
incident are to support tactical
military operations
from the beginning
our strategy to counter russia's tactics
has been to share what we know with the
world transparently and candidly we have
been right more than often more than
we'd like to
we're not going to let russia get away
with lying to the world are staining the
integrity of the security council by
using this forum as a venue for
legitimizing putin's violence
russia has attacked homes
schools
orphanages and hospitals russia has
attacked civilian infrastructure
including water and sanitation
facilities their forces are laying
ukrainian cities under siege
hundreds of thousands of civilians now
don't have access to electricity for
heat or drinking water to stay alive
russia is aggressive aggressor here
and fight his best effort
the media and everyday ukrainians are
documenting this truth on the ground
russia can't paint over the page the new
york times which on monday featured the
bodies of a ukrainian mother and her two
children who died while trying to cross
the bridge outside kiev in their attempt
to flee to safety
russia cannot cover up the work of ap
news reporters who captured a doctor
attempting to resuscitate an
eighteen-month-old kirill who died from
russian shilling in maripo
russia cannot suppress the social media
posts confirmed and amplified by cbs
news that told the story of the 11 year
old ukrainian boy who fled to slovakia
by himself
his own passport a plastic bag and a
phone number scrawled on his hands
russia cannot silence the al jazeera
report of russian soldiers terrorizing
ukrainian cities
and ukrainian journalists are risking
their lives every day to deliver to the
world the latest on the ground facts
such as novo vernier
uh reporting on the reckless behavior of
russian forces toward ukraine's nuclear
facilities
russia is failing in his quest to create
an alternative reality in fact not even
russian diplomats can keep their
propaganda straight
just yesterday the kremlin spokesman
said he didn't have clear information
about the russian forces who fired on
eternity hospital
then the foreign minister himself denied
russia attacked ukraine at all
right before admitting that russia
deliberately
targeted this maternity hospital in
liverpool
their fabrications didn't matter because
the world had already seen the searing
images broadcast on in of bloodied
pregnant women being evacuated from the
scene of russia's attack in the hospital
even russian
russia's own citizens are tiring of such
lies
russian athletes are writing no war on
their shoes and on
tv cameras
russian citizens are marching in the
streets and protesting putin's war of
choice
and even russian state tv pundits
putin's own propaganda on half putin to
stop the military action
this is why we didn't object to holding
today's eating
diseasing has confirmed our predictions
reveal russia's objectives to the world
and expose russia's lies for what they
are a malicious effort to cover for the
atrocities being committed by russia as
part of their illegal and unprovoked
attack on ukraine
it is a page directly out of the russian
playbook and it will not convince us one
bit
the world is watching photographic and
video evidence is mounting and you will
be held to account for your actions we
will not let a custody slide
unlike the russian government
first
distance
we are confident
truth and transparency will prevail
we call on president putin to end this
unprovoked unconscionable war against
the ukrainian people thank you
laboratories
is
furthermore
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
against the war in russia
of the united kingdom
thank you mr president
bashar has today
brought the security council
a series of wild
completely baseless
and irresponsible conspiracy theories
let me put diplomatically
they are utter nonsense
there is not a shred of credible
evidence
that ukraine has a biological weapons
programme
ukraine is a state party to the
biological and toxin weapons convention
in good standing
as we've heard
the research facilities
are established facilities
set up to deal public health hazards
the un briefers today have confirmed
this
this is yet another lie in russia's
disinformation campaign
they said
they would not invade ukraine
they then invaded
venezuela then said they hadn't invaded
and he repeated this absurdity yesterday
a whole pack of lies
they said ukraine was preparing a dirty
bomb
that was a lie too
they said yesterday that a pregnant
woman staged her injuries in the mario
hospital bombing
that was a grotesque eye
russia is sinking to new depths today
but this council must not get dragged
down with it
so let's get back to the facts
russia is invading ukraine in violation
of international law
russia is killing hundreds of civilians
through indiscriminate shelling of
ukrainian cities
it is using cluster munitions
and thermobaric rockets
weapons designed to inflict maximum
damage
wherever they are deployed
it is targeting hospitals and schools
and committing war crimes
thousands of russian and ukrainian
soldiers are dead
deaths
that will shatter the lives of families
they left behind
2.5 million ukrainians have become
refugees why
children forced to flee from president
putin's invasion
this
is a war of choice that russia needs to
end
colleagues
russia has broken its commitments under
the chatter
but we must not let it subvert the
multilateral system itself
as the un said today
russia is now putting at threat
the global framework for peace and
security
the security council
is responsible for addressing many
serious conflicts
around the world
we have important work to do
we do not sit in this chamber to be an
audience for russia's domestic
propaganda
and we should not allow russia
to abuse its permanent seat
to spread disinformation and lies
and pervert the purpose of the security
council
let us resolve today
that this council
remains focused
on the real threat to international
peace and security
i thank you
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom for her statement
i give the floor to the representative
of india
thank you mr president
i thank usg nakamitsu and usd de carlo
for their briefings
we have to
real states by dates
and wider information regarding the
biological activities relating to
ukraine
in this context
we would like to underline the important
attached by india to the biological and
sin weapons convention btwc
as a key global and non-discriminatory
disarmament convention
prohibiting an entire category of
weapons mass destruction
it is important to ensure full and
effective implementation of the btwc
in letter and spirit
we also believe that any matters
relating to obligations under the btwc
should be addressed as for the
provisions of the convention
and through consultation and cooperation
between the park's return
mr president we have repeatedly
expressed serious concern over the
ongoing situation in ukraine
we sincerely hope that ongoing direct
negotiations between russia and ukraine
would lead secession of hostilities
there is no other alternative
except the path diplomacy and dialogue
the dire humanitarian situation needs
immediate and urgent attention
we once again call upon member states to
adhere to the principles of the u.n
charter
international law and respect the
sovereignty and integrity of states i
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of india for
his statement
i now give
[Music]
organizations
united nations
is
[Music]
and
thank you very much
and let me begin by thanking the high
representative for disarmament affairs
and the usg political and peace build
affairs rosemary dicarlo for their
briefings to the council this morning
i also welcome my participation in this
meeting of the representative of ukraine
mr president ghana has taken do you
careful note of the beefings
and the remark of the remarks of
delegations that are spoken before us
we believe that on account of the
information before as a determination of
ukraine's biological programs can only
be made after further assessment by
relevant institutions
such as a health organization to
establish the situation of the
biological laboratories under
concentration
and the state of infectious disease
research that we're being undertaking
therein
it is in this regard that we have the
parties to respect the call for an
unconditional immediate ceasefire
and for the russian federation to
withdraw off its invading troops from
the internationally recognized borders
of ukraine bearing in mind the
incarceral consequences that an
accidental
or deliberate release of chemical
biological agents in the conflict
theater
could have on the populations in and
around ukraine
but also on global stability and an
already fragile security environment
the polarization of chemical and
biological agents in the war ukraine or
anywhere else
would be wrong
dash
leaving me contemplated
as a state party to the biological
workforce convention
we believe that the call for a
verification regime for the bwc
continues to be valid
and that such an additional protocol
could be done in a manner that is
reasonable and sensible
especially in light of recent global
development including the coveted 19
pandemic
ghana romantically concerned about the
escalation of military bombardments and
terrorist cities
of ukraine
which have given rise to a rapidly
deteriorating humanitarian situation
described by many other west in europe
since the end of the second world war
we are also concerned by the
transmission of shocks the war in
ukraine with the global economy
and the disproportionate impact that
developing countries and small economies
are having to bear on the count of this
war
many of whom are already in the truths
of the coveted 19 pandemic
and contend with the deaths of several
thousands from the socio-economic
consequences
of
the pandemic beyond the scope of global
attention
international solidarity is therefore
important even though we maintain global
cohesion and stability
we remind the foreign parties of the
obligation to respect and comply with
their commitments under international
law
international humanitarian law and human
rights law
in particular we call for the protection
of civilians and humanitarian workers in
ukraine
in accordance with the provisions of the
4th geneva convention of 1949 relative
to the protection of campaigns
in the time war
mr president in concluding let me recall
ghana's long-held view that the
possession of proliferation of weapons
of mass destruction
including chemical and biological
weapons neither assures international
peace nor national security
we all therefore have a responsibility
to ensure that we eliminate such
performance
from the present civilization we are
seeking to build i thank you very much
for your kind attention
for his statement i give floor to the
representative of ireland
thank you very much mr president and i'd
like to thank the higher representative
nakamitsu and under secretary general de
carlo for their
sober briefings this morning
mr president ireland deeply regrets the
decision russian duration called today's
muting meeting
it has done so for no other reason than
to advance baseless claims against
ukraine and the united states
ireland has a long-standing and clear
policy on biological chemical
there was mass destruction
it is intolerable that russia as part of
its attempts to excuse its unjustifiable
and unlawful aggression against ukraine
is making unsubstantiated and unfounded
claims against ukraine
regarding the alleged development and
possible use
biological weapons
the prohibitions on biological
and chemical weapons must not be
undermined
given the reckless disregard for nuclear
safety and security shown by russian
forces since the start of the invasion
there are fears for cbrn safety arising
from the invasion
no way
claims of weapons of mass destruction
development in ukraine
we are familiar with this approach by
the russian federation
it forms part of a long-standing pattern
by the confederation to use
disinformation and multiple multilateral
fora to distract deny and cover up its
own transgressions and aggressions
ireland considers it unacceptable
to levy such accusations against ukraine
a state party in good standing to the
treaty of the non-proliferation of
nuclear weapons
chemical weapons convention and the
biological weapons convention
these instruments are doing their right
job of ensuring non-proliferation of
weapon mass production
so no abs has been advanced to support
such allegations in these four
earlier this week 48 states including
ireland challenged these unsubstantiated
claims by
the oecw
i urge the russian federation to cease
its campaign of disinformation and not
to use this council as a platform to
spread disinformation
such harmful actions demean this body
and its role in maintaining
international peace and security
mr president the russia federation's
invasion of ukraine has created a
humanitarian catastrophe
in another effort to mislead and
misinform we've been told the russian
federation
that the humanitarian crisis we are
seeing in ukraine is not a result of its
actions
however as u.n briefers confirmed again
today it is clear that the russian
offensive is causing the suffering of
millions resulting in a rapidly rising
toll of internally displaced persons and
refugees in need of humanitarian
assistance
millions of people in ukraine are
struggling with the humanitarian
consequences of this senseless
aggression
whatever's agreed not agreed on
humanitarian safe passage civilians and
civilian infrastructure must be
protected
compliant with international
humanitarian law is not optional
it is an obligation
full safe and unhindered access to
provide humanitarian assistance is
urgently needed
mr president
one more time ireland urges the russian
federation to immediately cease
hostilities
unconditionally withdrawal from the
entire territory of ukraine
and refrain from further threat or use
of force of any kind
against ukraine
it is
undefined to dialogue and diplomacy the
only pathway to resolve conflict
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of ireland
for her statement give the floor to
norway
thank you president
and i thank usg ricardo
and our representative nakamitsu for
their statements
two weeks ago the russian federation
in blatant violation of international
law
chose to wedge an oatman war against its
peaceful neighbor ukraine
we regret our condemnation of these acts
of aggression
a few days later
james used its veto to prevent the
security council from for fulfilling its
mandate to maintain international peace
and security
and today russia has called for a
meeting based on an uncollaborated
narrative insinuating that ukraine is
developing biological weapons
this impacts the credibility of this
council
let us not forget the real threat to
international peace and security that we
are witnessing
an illegal war waged by the russian
federation against another sovereign
u.n member state
and we condemn the use of cluster
munition by the russian federation
confirmed here today
the russian invasion was preceded by
fabricated claims and unfounded
allegations
and it is intolerable that russia now
makes the unsubstantiated claim that
ukraine was preparing aggressive action
with the use of biological weapon
similar allegations have also emerged
when it comes to chemical weapons
production
as we heard from the u.n briefers
it is they are not available
that ukraine has developed or planned to
use either chemical or biological
weapons
president
norway remains a storm supporter of the
biological weapons convention which
remains one of the pillars of this
moment
and the
non-proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction together with
non-proliferation treaty and chemical
weapons convention
and we condemn any use of such weapons
which
would constitute a clear violation of
these conventions
the convention have established a total
ban on chemical and biological weapons
all states parties were obliged to
destroy their stocks or such weapons
when they entered into these two
agreements
universal adherence and full
implementation by all states parties are
key
and i would like to remind that russian
must as a party to both conventions
uphold their international obligation
just like all states parties must
chemical and biological record cannot
and must not be used in war
president
i'm deeply concerned by the growing
humanitarian crisis in ukraine
and we are appalled by the blatant lack
of respect for international
humanitarian law displayed by the
russian military forces
in particular the disregard for the
obligation to protect the ukrainian
civilian population
every day we see numerous report of
russian shelling of homes school
hospitals and other critical civilian
infrastructure
this is unacceptable and must stop
the horrifying report from this week's
attack on a medical facility in mariopol
are yet another example of the
disrespect for international
humanitarian law
the space for humanitarian action must
be restored and it must be protected in
a way that ensures continuous and
sustained humanitarian access
russia must end this war now we need a
withdrawal of all forces
and engagement in good faith through the
political
growing complexity and sensitivity
what is most needed now continues to be
to intensify diplomatic efforts reduce
tension
and bring the european eq back to
the political settlement as soon as
possible
while making efforts to prevent a
massive large-scale humanitarian crisis
stop fighting and hostilities is a
widespread desire of the international
community
peace negotiations are only
two
all foreign are positive steps towards
achieving peace
the international community should
continue to encourage and support
russia and ukraine in their negotiations
and
create necessary environment and
conditions for such peace talks china
will continue to work with the
international community and play its
part in de-escalating the situation and
seeking peace
of all wmds including
biological weapons firmly opposite the
development possession and the use of
biological and chemical weapons by any
country and under any circumstances
and encourage those countries that have
not yet
destroyed their
dog piles of chemical weapons to do as
soon as possible the purposes and
principles of the biological weapons
convention should be strictly upheld
logical weapons
mass destruction
any information and at least
military activities should trigger high
attention from the international
community china has noted with the
concern right of the information
released by russia
the biological weapons convention is an
obligation for all state parks
the concerns raised by russia should be
properly addressed china urges the
parties to effectively implement their
obligation under the convention
providing a comprehensive classification
and accept
verification we have to take the note of
the press report that the who has
advised to the ukrainian government to
destroy the pathogens located in those
labs in order to prevent the spread of
infectious diseases we look forward to
be receiving more
specific informations on this under the
current situation
of public health we call for ensuring
the safety and security of relevant
laboratories
mr president
the u.s representative in her statement
made
a
the international community have been
raising concerns about the us military
biological activities
they
the u.s they are foreign
so that the international community
community can do a conclusion myself
thank you mr president
i would like to be a representative of
china for his statement and give the
floor to brazil
thank you mr president
mr president
biological weapons were the first
category of weapon of mass destructions
to be subject to comprehensive
prohibition
the biologic the biological weapons
commission
pwc adopted in 1972
binds all state parties to the
obligation to
and i quote
never in any circumstances to develop
produce
or otherwise acquire
such weapons
and of course
brazil
believes that any accusations
regarding violations of the basic
prohibitions set out by the bwc are
extremely serious
and as such
must be thoroughly substantiated by
solid evidence
such evidence must be presented
through and confirmed by an independent
and impartial authority s for c in
article 4 of the biological weapons
convention
it is unfortunate
that such investigation mechanisms are
not strong enough at the moment
brazil also believes that legitimate
scientific
and technological research on biosafety
and biosecurity should be kept distinct
and separate from possible violations of
the prohibition against the development
and production of biological weapons if
we wish to preserve the bwc regime
research into new and
dangerous pathogens
should be subject to strict transparency
mechanisms
brazil has long favored
the negotiation of a multilateral
verification protocol as a complement to
the d to the pwc
with additional measures to guarantee
protection and security against emerging
biological threats
the situation before the council today
only reinforces the urgency and
necessity of such a mechanism
brazil strongly condemns the use or
threat of use of weapons of mass
destruction
including biological and chemical
weapons
anywhere by anyone under any
circumstances
i thank you
for the representative of brazil for his
statement and give the floor to the
representative of kenya
thank you mr president
i thank usg medical
and representative nakamitsu for
their briefings and i welcome the
participation of the representative of
ukraine
the conflict in your
counties at an acceptable cost
to the people of ukraine
and increasingly to the entire world
as the prices of essential commodities
rise
sharply
our hearts go to the families who have
lost loved ones
as well as the millions of refugees and
internally displaced persons
we are also greatly concerned that the
armed conflict
has not spared objects indispensable to
the survival of civilian populations
including presidential homes
health facilities as well as power and
water infrastructure
mr president
we have listened with deep concern to
the syrian allegations
of the development
of biological reps
in contravention
of the convention on the prohibition of
the development production and
stockpiling of biological and toxin
weapons
the security council
as mandated in the biological weapons
convention
he obliged to consider complaints
brought forward by any state party to
the convention against the breach of
this convention
the convention
weighs the security council with the
responsibility to consider
whether to carry out an investigation
should a state party formally launch a
complaint to trigger such a process
we must make the obvious observation
that there would need to be a hold to
the armed conflict to enable an
investigation
that mr president
will then bring us to precisely same
situation where we are in today
even as ukraine and russia's diplomats
have just met in antarctica
agreed basis for a ceasefire
we help them double efforts
and to make use of the willingness of
many countries to lend their heavy
assistance to their talks
mr president
the risks of this conflict broadening
and escalating
should be taken with extreme seriousness
already
its effects are being experienced far
outside ukraine
the sanctions and counter sanctions are
threatening world food supply
and rapid energy price increases
will drive millions more people into
poverty
even as they struggle to recover from
its
impact
humanity is chilling on the edge of a
precipice
becoming economic shock
if a ceasefire is not imminently
announced
would be accompanied by political crisis
and more conflict situations
in regard to the serious allegations we
have had
whatever action is undertaken in the
security council
should be matched by a newfound
commitment
by all member states
to the biological weapons convention
we urge its 183 states parties to seize
the opportunity the ninth review
conference later this year to strengthen
the political weapons regime
and the norms that safeguard humanity
from the threat of use of these
according weapons
ultimately mr president the only way out
of this crisis is to pause the armed
conflict and give a chance to dialogue
to shape a stable european security
order in which the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of all members is
protected
area from kenya's recognition of the
sovereignty territorial integrity and
political independence of ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders i
thank you
thank you mr president
the serious accusations
is
foreign
is
[Music]
emerge from crisis thank you
representative
for his statement
of the russian federation
[Music]
we expected
to which a guilty mind is never at ease
[Music]
huge level
of
suffering suffering victims and
destruction
which then reverberated in the whole
region reverberated also in the form of
a terrorist organization called
[Music]
biological programs in uh
musicians
they didn't exist in actual fact
military development is a secret
enterprise and those who are involved
to the ground
raised this issue many times but this
died and this titan was buried
atrocities of the russian army attacks
on hospitals kindergarten schools
maternity prosecutors using cluster
bombs something that
that was refuted repeatedly by our
ministry
the majority of hospital number one
in marijuana has
has become um the common parlance in
this regard
did you listen to what we said here in
this room on monday the 9th of march
said that the fight was a radical
converted to that building
into an
destroyed a maternity hospital the bling
i think it was destroyed
is there a building without windows it's
not destroyed here are the photos
so we have the videos from inside the
building
once again can you imagine what kind of
construction
near
is
is using two different kinds of makeup
to present herself as two different
women in photographs and this is
something that that was revealed by the
network users
are dismayed by the dirty campaign to
blame us for intentionally telling a
civilian
a special psychological operation
at the same time
going forward
um in
silence over the fact that you basically
shut off your access to russia
we found a great deal of new
things these days
of speech that you seem to champion i
would like to react now
my uh uk colleagues
and it is true that the war was not
begun by us that started eight years ago
by the key of
uh
[Music]
which apparently they used to arrive
there here's a picture
bearing a logo of the united nations
uh
[Music]
is unacceptable
i think the representative
the united states
foreign
i know that
i know that you expect me to
respond
but we're not going to give any more air
time to the lies that you're hearing
today is beneath this council
and there's only one aggressor here and
that is russia and we hope they will be
able to find it in their conscience to
end the attacks and stop the suffering
of the ukrainian people thank you
for the representative of
ukraine
thank you yeah mr president
distinguished members of the security
council
madame under secretary general de carlo
madam under secretary general nakamitsu
i should also acknowledge the presence
of a separate category here
a representative of the aggressive state
who sits in the state of the soviet
union
in the security council
the status of which was recognized by
the general assembly resolution es
11-1 and that is the status of
aggressive state
there is already a long record of
russian lies established here in the
council
and only the recollection of the items
of lies over the last two weeks will
take perhaps uh
an hour or so
but let me mention just
a couple lowest of the lowest
and i would not hesitate to mention them
again after the
representative sitting in soviet seat i
just said refer to them
let me quote his king kingpin
russian foreign minister lavrov
who said yesterday indeed
i quote we
plan to attack other countries with not
that ukraine either
and of course
an outlet of the russian lies the
russian embassy in london
tweeted yesterday that a pregnant woman
is uh in the attack on the hospital in
mariupol was wearing makeup
and was playing the multiple
was playing multiple roles of pregnant
women
and indeed
marco
and the russian ambassador here are
struggling to get this story straight
kremlin spokesman
discovered
reuters
in the immediate aftermath of the month
of the strike on monday that i quote
russian forces not fire on steel and
targets end of quote
on thursday he told reporters that the
crime would look into the incident i
quote because you and i
don't have clear information about what
happened there end of quote
following a meeting with the ukrainian
foreign minister and turkey owners the
russian foreign minister level took a
different stance
as he claimed without evidence that the
hospital in mariopol was a warranted
target because the building had been
seized long ago by ukrainian armed
groups
let me
with you a very good news
miss mariana the pregnant woman
gave birth to a healthy daughter last
night
her name
is veronica
here she is with her father
no matter what
the rationalized
are
about yourself your family
and the incident
mr president whatever the gentleman in
the soviet seat may say in
reply is most probably useless
we need to hear directly from the
mastermind of the war crimes committed
so far
as we established that he was out of
loop on many occasions having no clue
what was going on on the ground
we know quite well that the manic
obsession with which putin fantasized
this
about non-existent biological or
chemical weapons or hazards in ukraine
is very dangerous
it may actually point at russia
preparing another horrific false flag
operation
so what else are you going to use
against ukraine cruise missiles multiple
rocket launchers heavy aerial bombs
we have already experienced all of these
what is
ammonia phosphorus
and what will be the next target
one more residential building
one more maternity hospital
one more school
or maybe one more cultural heritage site
russian groups have already eat all
these
types all of them
by calling this meeting
the aggressive state
has shoot itself in foot once again
ukraine runs a health system that is
totally in full compliance with these
international obligations
and in full cooperation with all
relevant international organizations
the arrest is is binding of insane
delirium
of putin and his henchmen
including
russian mission to the united nations
russia does not give a monkeys about
safety of his own citizens
including thousands of
the imposing bodies of russian soldiers
soldiers send by putin to ukraine
to this ongoing garbage
i regret that the security council is
being now manipulated
by the russian federation to promote
such an insane lirium
this is not much disregard by the
russian federation of the members of
security council
finally is detrimental for the council
credibility
what indeed had to be addressed by the
council on war crimes and crimes against
humanity that the russian federation
commits on a daily basis since 24th of
february
the day when the war in europe unleashed
by russia started
among the most recent examples that
shocked the world
russian airstrike that destroyed
maternity hospital that we already
mentioned so many times today
russian indiscriminate shellings and
aspects have almost destroyed mariupol
one of the most beautiful cities
on the isle of sea
and kill
1582
civilian residents of the city according
to the local administration
for the first time
since the world war ii people are being
buried in mass graves in ukrainian
cities
i would like to use this opportunity to
ask gentlemen in the soil seat
if you already connected wire to moscow
please talk to moscow
to release the kidnapped mayor of the
city of melee topple
help
us get him back
from the arms of the invaders
and many other ukrainian cities are
being raised to the ground
documents and maps ceased by the
ukrainian troops from russian prisoners
of ball confirmed that bombardments of
residential areas had been planned in
advance captured russian pilots at
today's press conference in kiev have
reconfirmed that they deliberately
dropped the bombs on residential areas
the number of civilians killed by the
russian troops exceeds military losses
many people have lost their homes more
than
1.5 million left ukraine almost 2
million by now
across the western border
hundreds of thousands if not millions
came idp
only from harker six hundred thousand
people were activated by trains
the main efforts are now focused on
ensuring safe passage of civilians
through humanitarian corridors
unfortunately the arrangements are often
violated by the russian troops
awful pictures and footages taken near
the destroyed breach in european with
killed civilians including entire
families who tried to flee the occupied
areas have circled and clarified
the globe
russia must not use silence as hostages
in human shield
by exposing cities
to indiscriminate shelling and creating
a dire humanitarian situation
deliberately shelling civilians during
the art evacuation from the besieged
ukrainian cities russia is forcing
civilians to flee their homes and
providing only a corridor to easter or
so-called green corridors proposed by
the aggressor sending people to russia
and belarus could be considered as
forcible deportation
of protected persons according to
international humanitarian law
mr president
ukrainian people are being killed and
ukrainian cities are being destroyed as
we are
compelled to listen to the russian
absurd fake since council
fakes created in a desperate attempt
to fight wash
the war against ukraine
russian aggression threatens
us all and there is an urgent need to be
resolute
in
countering uncivilized barbaric and mean
actions by russia
the sooner the aggressor is stopped and
hold accountable for his crimes this is
how
our world will be
i will not end
before i read several paragraphs
from an open letter from 194
bubble loris
i could
the other signed nobel laureates who is
our support
for the ukrainian people
and the free and independent state of
ukraine as it faces russian aggression
194 nobel laureates
in a move that recalls the infamous
attack of nazi germany
full of 1849
using similar tricks
of faint provocation
the government of the russian federation
led by president putin has launched an
unprovoked military aggression
nothing else but a wall
against its neighbor ukraine
we choose our warriors carefully here
who we do not believe the russian people
have a role in this aggression
we join in condemning these military
actions and presidents putin's essential
incessant essential denial of the
legitimacy
of ukraine's existence
we respect
the calm and the strengths of the
ukrainian people
we are with you
our hearts go out to the families and
friends of all ukrainians and russians
who have died and been injured already
may peace come this
peace of our beautiful world
and of course i thank you
ukrainians
i need to use adjourned
so
all right
oh
go ahead
they come out here
[Music]
uh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
look at that
[Music]
um
oh
[Music]
oh
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful
just quickly
you've heard what just went on in the
council and i just want to say
we believe in truth
we believe in facts
we believe our eyes and our ears we
actually believe what you are reporting
every single day
we believe independent media we believe
the world is bearing witness to a war of
russian aggression and no matter how
much russia tries it can't change that
that's what today showed and it
continues to show that russia is the
aggressor here no one else
thank you
[Music]